[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section let me
hear from you we bet we're the biggest
fans of the loud house ever we've
managed to find some amazing
illustrations that will show you what
the young members of the loud family
will look like in the future make sure
you watch this video until the end to
see what Lana would look like as a
teenager
Ola did you hear about our latest
addition to our family their richest
espanol is the perfect place for all
your native Spanish speakers out there
don't speak Spanish no problem come on
over this is the perfect place to
practice amazing facts interesting
people and funny pictures those ammos
ahi now let's look at ten loud house
characters reimagined as teenagers Lily
although we talk a lot about her older
siblings we never really pay much
attention to the 15 month old Lily loud
well all that is about to change we
found quite a few pictures of what Lily
loud would look like as a teenager and
although we have no idea what her
personality will be we can imagine she
will be just as unique as the rest of
her siblings but as we wait for her to
grow up we thought we'd give you a
little sneak peek of what these talented
artists think Lily would look like in
her teens the first illustration belongs
to a deviantART user Anton discs
who gave Lily a school uniform and cute
blonde hair J boy 32x also made a pretty
good version of what Lily will possibly
look like when she's Lincoln's age
doesn't she look adorable
we love that he kept her buck tooth
here's another slightly older and much
bolder version of Lily designed by mr.
Crabb x10 undi vien tart younger sisters
love to borrow older sisters stuff
without asking and you can clearly see
her sisters had a huge influence on this
version of Lily we can even spot Lenny
classes these illustrations do make us
wonder what personality will Lily have
in the future do you think she'll be
anything like her brother or sisters
Lisa the four year old Lisa loud is the
second youngest in the family but she
proves that age is not important because
this little one comes with unbelievable
intelligence that earned her a Nobel
Peace Prize
we love Lisa and we've previously shown
her what she look like as a boy and as a
bodybuilder but these illustrations of
Lisa as a teenager are some of our
favorites because she's so smart Lisa is
skipping grades like nobody's business
by the time she's a teenager she'll
probably get a fancy scientist job we
love her but we also love these
fantastic illustrations check them out
see Bart on deviantART gave us a pretty
good preview of the four year old Lisa
in her teenage years with these
fantastic pictures usually Lisa is
unamused by pretty much everything but
at 16 she is finally smiling
we knew she'd come around been lulu-nee
also managed to recreate an awesome
looking teenage Lisa we also found this
illustration by the loud house fan who
decided to give Lisa a dress instead of
her usual green sweater
she's also cracking a small smile and
she put her hair up it's definitely
surprising to see a different side of
Lisa and we can't wait to see what
she'll actually look like as a teenager
we bet you'll only get smarter and
she'll probably be the world's most
famous scientist Lenny the 16 year old
Lenny is the second oldest of the family
but unlike her older sister she's much
more loving and caring toward her
younger siblings she's a fashionista of
the family and although she can be very
dizzy and naive we love her for a
carefree attitude
Lenny loud is already 16 but we found
some amazing illustrations that show her
in a slightly different teenage version
of the Lenny you know we all know Lenny
is stylish so here are some of the most
stylish photos we've managed to find
check out this variation created by
Dragan Kyle 44 on deviantART mr. Krab
x10 made
slightly taller and Dark Mirror emo 23
made her slightly older and equipped
with all her favorite accessories but
our favorite has to be this teenaged
version of Lenny done by the loud house
fan from deviantART who added a sailor
moon outfit to her look we can
definitely see Lenny modeling fashion
trends like this in her teenage hood
before settling on her current look
which is equally as cute we can't decide
which one of these illustrations is our
favorite but we can definitely tell you
that Lenny is one of our favorite
characters see Bart also created this
slightly younger teenage Lory and it
looks like she's not yet added the
stylish sunglasses to her iconic look
who wouldn't want an older sister who's
such a fashionista but still good at
heart
Lynn as the sporty one of the family the
13 year old Lynne is the most
competitive if you have a lot of
siblings we bet there's at least one of
you who loves to turn everything into a
competition you're definitely not the
only one Lynne is already a teenager but
we managed to find several versions of
her looking slightly older she
definitely still looks 40 we bet she's
just as competitive here she is looking
as cute as ever in her sporty outfit
this image belongs to the fresh Knight
on deviantART who also decided to dress
land up in stylish Yeezys see Bart gave
us a whole timeline of what Lynn would
look like at different ages and we love
her look at 16 she seems more mature and
it's the first time we're seeing her
with her hair down and here she is as a
coach this illustration belongs to Jay
boy 32 X and even though Lynn is 23
years old on this picture we can see her
becoming a famous coach and make her
team win all championships at a much
younger age even though Lynn's
competitiveness can sometimes ruin the
family fun you have to admit the loud
family wouldn't be the same without her
she's so talented when it comes to
sports we bet she will become an Olympic
champion in more than just one
discipline
luann of course we can't forget about
Luanne when it comes to our favorite
loud house characters the hilarious
Luanne loud is definitely one of our top
five although all of them have their own
unique and lovable personalities she's
absolutely pol arias even though our
jokes sometimes fall flat with the rest
of her family
don't worry Luanne we get you Luanne is
14 years old but we'll show her in
different stages of her teenage hood the
first illustration belongs to J boy 32x
who made Luanne look taller but we love
that she's still wearing her signature
yellow outfit
Luanne definitely looks older here but
we can see her looking like this as a 17
year old see Bart gave her slightly
longer hair but also kept her cute
yellow fashion look she looks about 15
years old and she's totally adorable you
can't deny that Luanne is one of the few
characters that can definitely pull off
that yellow outfit jump around jump jump
better look younger but doesn't she look
like she's a lot of fun here's another
picture from this same artist she looks
awesome
we can definitely see Luanne becoming
one of the most popular comedians out
there and have her own show even as a
teenager of course we still expect her
to continue to annoy her family with
pranks and her hilarious puns Lola the
six-year-old Lola is a pageant diva we
can't help but love even though Ms Lola
is sometimes rough on her siblings she's
sassy and as hilarious moments that make
us love her she's one of the girliest
members of the family who loves to dress
up and of course show off her beauty in
pageants she's only six years old
so we found a few versions of what she'd
look like as a teenager
see Bart showed us what Lola would look
like at 11 and also 16 we love how she
sticks to her signature pink color and
we bet she'll win over thousands of
pageants by the time she's 16 and while
we love her cute chip tooth at the age
of 6 it's interesting to see her full
smile at 16 nautical pudding on
deviantART also presented her at an
older age and we absolutely loved her
long blonde hair J boy 32 X made her
hair even longer and gave her a cute
pink headband whilst rats turned her
into a
real-life princess doesn't she look like
she'd be a perfect character for the
next Disney Princess we love her tiara
her pink dress and the long gloves she
definitely looks a lot more graceful
than the feisty six-year-old Lola we
know from the loud house we expect her
to win all kinds of beauty titles
including Miss USA Lincoln can you
imagine having ten sisters with unique
personalities and being the only boy in
the family the 11 year old Lincoln has
always been our favorite because we just
can't believe he's managing to survive
the madness that is the loud house of
course he also wished to have brothers
but is seen that having sisters is a
much better option
Lincoln is just about to enter his
teenage years and we found you at the
loud house fans think he'll look like
our first two illustrations belong to J
boy 32x
you can see Lincoln definitely got
taller in the first image although the
artist claims this is him at 21 we do
see some of his features like his longer
hair come out during his teenage years
the second image shows him with Ronnie
an his school crush who was actually
pretty mean to him until she admitted
she likes him we also found this
ridiculously cute slightly younger
version of Lincoln created by C Bart we
loved his chipped tooth and it looks
like his white hair is beginning to grow
out of control
Lincoln's personality is much more chill
than the rest of his siblings but we do
wonder what'll excel at later in life we
can see him take on jobs as a writer or
a video game developer as he loves
anything related to fiction the whole
family just in case we'll miss anyone in
this video here's an illustration was
done by the talented C Bart that shows
every single loud sibling at the age of
16 are they completely adorable
we love that lenio stayed the same but
the rest of them have either grown or
are looking slightly younger check them
out we have everyone from the youngest
and the family to the oldest doesn't
Lana look like Lenny and Lana and LuAnn
could practically be twins we also found
this illustration created by the
talented owner Eve on tumblr who
humanized the characters and made them
slightly more real some of them
definitely look like they've hit their
teenage years it's hard to believe that
this colorful family was once a family
of 25 rabbits yes Chris Savino initially
created the loud house rabbit characters
and eventually change them to adorable
humans we know today this is precisely
why Lincoln has white hair and some of
them feature a buck tooth do you think
the loud house will be on the air long
enough for us to see the entire family
go through their teenage stage we'd love
to see an actual loud house family
portrait once they look older but it
looks like deviantART see Bart gave us a
pretty good preview we can't even
imagine everything they're going to
achieve once they're older Lucy Lucy is
only 8 years old but she's already going
through a phase some of us went through
as teenagers
she's always dressed in dark clothing
and she's incredibly moody but we of
course still love her we adore her
sarcasm even though she sometimes
scary-looking even to her own family
members although her older teenage look
is practically the same we do love this
version of Lucy check it out
J boy 32x reimagined her as a quite
fashionable teenage girl even though
she's still rocking her dark look on the
other hand CB arts version of Lizzie is
slightly different while she still
features her signature dark clothing she
no longer has bangs that cover up most
of her face her hair is longer and she's
wearing a dress this deviantART user
also showed her in a dress we loved her
long dark hair and the black-and-white
sleeve covers and leggings we can
totally see Lucy looking like this when
she hits her teenage years master oh
yeah from deviantART also illustrated
her in a unique way this Lucy sports
much shorter hair but it definitely fits
her look he calls her the Duchess of
darkness and it definitely is a perfect
title for this moody character do you
think her mood will ever improve or will
she forever rock dark clothing and
entertain us with her sarcastic cummins
Lana and we can't forget about the six
year old Lana who's probably the biggest
tomboy if he went through a tomboy phase
in your childhood we bet you can really
identify with her character Lana loves
to do all the dirty work her sisters
preferred not to do and she especially
loves playing in the
bud she's only six but we wonder if the
teenage version of Lana would still
prefer to be a tomboy
rather than a girly girl we'll have to
wait to find out in the meantime here
are some amazing illustrations of what
Lana would look like in her teenage
years see Bart definitely thinks Lana
might look slightly less tomboyish when
she's 16
check her out she actually reminds us of
Wendy from gravity falls on this picture
however nautical pudding reimagined what
Lana would look like at 14 and she's
definitely still rockin her usual look
you can even see mud spots on her shirt
like Lenny on deviantART Illustrated her
as a slightly different but still cute
version we love her pigtails Cruella
Deville 184 showed us what both Lana and
Lola would look like at 16 and we love
that both girls look significantly
taller of course Lana's still rocking
her red snapback it's hard enough to
choose a favorite loud sibling but it's
even harder to choose which of these
amazing illustrations we prefer what do
you think Lana would look like as a
teenager you can't deny it the loud
house is one of the most popular
Nickelodeon cartoons of 2016 and 2017
the cartoon explores the chaotic lives
of the loud family ever wondered what
those kids will look like when they grow
up just wait until you see Laurie today
we're checking out ten loud house
characters all grown up Lisa loud you
might have noticed we didn't introduce
the 15 month old Lily loud and that's
because we want to see her grow up on
the actual show so let's start with Lisa
the second youngest of the bunch we all
know that Lisa loud is an exceptionally
intelligent four-year-old remember the
time she made a portal that connected
the world of Fairly OddParents to the
world of the loud house now some fans
are petitioning for a similar crossover
with SpongeBob SquarePants and we bet
Lisa can make it all happen Lisa is a
kindergarten student but she's so
advanced for her age she can also teach
at a university she is known for her
typical don't mess with my thing's face
which we've also seen on dexter from
dexters laboratory
what the four-year-old Lisa would look
like as an 11 year old it's seven years
later and Lisa still has her famous look
but she seems a lot taller her short
hair is now long and put in a ponytail
we bet she's just too busy inventing new
things to get her hair cut this awesome
illustration belongs to a talented
deviantART user C Bart who is a devoted
loud house fan wonder what the rest of
the loud family looks like all grown up
let's check them out Lola loud next in
line is the third youngest of the family
Lola loud is a typical pageant queen
you'll find on shows such as toddlers
and tiaras this six year old loves to
look at herself in the mirror and as you
might have guessed her favorite color is
pink as a typical pageant princess Lola
is often seen wearing a pink dress a
necklace and a tiara she has long blonde
hair and she's missing her two front
teeth after all she's only six years old
here's an amazing illustration of what
Lola would look like at 18 while she
basically looks the same but like a real
princess she let her blonde hair grow
very long
she's also no longer missing her two
front teeth but she's still wearing lots
of pink did you know that Lola was
actually the name of the creators wiener
dog
speaking of Lola don't you think she
looks just like Elena Thompson from here
comes honey boo boo we bet Lola could
run her own pageant reality show lana
loud we can't talk about Lola without
mentioning her totally opposite twin
sister Lana it's hard to believe these
two are twins did you know that Lana was
actually one of kris savino's five
sisters while Lola prefers to dress up
like a princess Lana is much more of a
tomboy she loves to get her hands dirty
and enjoys playing around in the mud
she's also amazing at plumbing and loves
to pretty much fix anything that's
broken but wait until you see what lamb
allowed would look like at the age of 14
she'd be eight years older and obviously
much taller but it's clear that she
still has her tomboyish looks this
illustration
was created by the talented deviantART
user nautical pudding and we love it
just as much as we love their user name
from her muddy shirt it's clear that a
fourteen-year-old Lana still enjoys
playing in the mud we can imagine she
has a similar sporty personality to her
athletic 14 year old sister Lynne will
show you what she looks like as an adult
in just a little bit Lucie loud Lucie
loud is the fifth youngest of the family
but probably the biggest pessimist she
represents the goth phase most of us
went through when we were teenagers
dressed in black and white Lucy also
sports long bangs that fall way over her
eyes she's known to walk quietly and she
can easily scare her siblings as she
appears out of nowhere
Lucy's definitely our spirit animal we
love the fact that she says sigh instead
of actually sighing Lucy's only eight
years old so imagine what she'd look
like at 18 this illustration belongs to
the talented Jay boy 32x the 18 year old
Lucy definitely upgraded her look and
exchanged her long bangs for awesome
side bangs it looks like she also added
a few piercings in her ear and she's
wearing awesome looking high-heeled
boots
despite her smirk we bet she's still as
sarcastic and uninterested in the rest
of the world as she was when she was 8
Lincoln loud you know sometimes we feel
kind of bad for Lincoln having 10
sisters must be tough and although he
does have a best friend it doesn't help
that this best friend is also in love
with one of his sisters it seems like
Lincoln can't catch a break
but it's not all as bad as it seems
Lincoln actually does wish for 10
brothers at some point and then learns
that his sisters are somewhat more
overprotective and a lot less messy we
feel you Lincoln as the only boy in the
family the 11 year old Lincoln loves
anything related to sci-fi and he loves
playing video games
check out Lincoln at the age of 30 did
you know that the loud house characters
were actually first created as rabbits
this explains Lincoln's white
and his teeth which are highlighted even
more at the age of 30 this creative
illustration belongs to Jay boy 32x from
deviantART is that a mustache we see on
the 30 year old Lincoln or are those
just rabbit whiskers at this point we
really can't tell but we do love that
Lincoln is the only boy and the only
character with white hair
perhaps his hair grows white from all
the stress his sisters bring into his
life
Lynne aloud next in line on the loud
family tree is the 13 year old Lynne
loud unlike the rest of her sisters or
anyone else in the family Lynne is the
sportiest she's the fifth oldest and
she's named after her father as you
might know Lynne likes to turn
everything into a competition
now isn't that what most of your
siblings do to the 13 year old Lynne is
one of those siblings she's super
competitive which easily gets on the
rest of the family's nerves due to her
competitiveness it's also very easy to
get her in a fight or a confrontation
check out a 16 year old version of Lynne
she's pretty much the same she still
looks 40 but we do love her with her
hair down like that this design was done
by a deviantART user called C Bart who
has a whole collection of amazing loud
house characters reimagined in different
ways this illustration also shows what
Lynne would look like if she aged with
the show as she was 13 when the show
came out in 2016 at what age do you
think she'll make it to the Olympics
Luanne loud we've had some fun looking
at Lisa Lincoln Lola and other younger
loud siblings now let's take a look at
the four older sisters of the loud
family just like younger loud children
they come with unique personalities and
they are all equally annoying to each
other
LuAnn loud is 14 years old and to be
completely honest she might be one of
our favorites her nickname should be the
queen of bad jokes and cringy puns but
we have to admit they still end up
making us giggle even though they really
are completely pointless sometimes she's
also the prankster of the
and definitely the one to look out for
on the April Fool's Day she's always
dressed in yellow outfits and has her
long brown hair put in a ponytail
all right but let's cut to the chase
this is what Luanne would look like at
21 notice how she still has her buck
teeth and braces in one of the episodes
it was revealed she had braces since she
was little and it looks like they're
permanent perhaps it's just another way
for the Creator to show that these
characters were originally supposed to
be rabbits 21 year old Luanne definitely
looks all grown up we wonder if she'd
still be as entertaining seven years
later or did her career goals ever
change to honor Luanne tell us your best
joke in the comments
Luna loud have you ever noticed how hard
it is to choose a favorite from the loud
family we can't do it we do love all
characters on this show and some of them
are even our spirit animals but there's
just something about Luna that makes her
stand out from the rest this 15 year old
has a passion for rock music and she's
often referencing rock songs in every
episode Luna is wild but she also cares
about her siblings we love her carefree
attitude and the fact that she sometimes
speaks in a British accent
at 15 she's definitely one of the most
mature loud siblings so let's check out
what she looks like at 25 it looks like
rock never left this girl's soul just
like her sister Lucy
a grownup version of Luna sports quite a
few piercings in her ears her hair has
awesome purple highlights and her entire
outfit just screams punk rock we love
her upgraded skull shirt overall her
facial features haven't really changed
but we do feel that she's an even bigger
rock chick than before while five of the
loud sisters were named after the
creator's own siblings Luna is pretty
much original from her looks to her name
and she looks just as cool at 15 as she
does it 25 blenny allowed next in line
is the 16 year old Lennie loud Lennie is
the second oldest in the loud family but
if there's anything this show is
teaching us is that age
really doesn't matter Lenny is a typical
teenager she can be very naive and ditzy
but she's exceptionally kind and caring
toward all her siblings
she's pretty easygoing but she's
probably one of the least intelligent
characters out of the bunch don't worry
she makes it up with her caring attitude
Lenny is suffering from arachnophobia
which is a fear of spiders we totally
feel you Lenny we hate spiders too so
what do you think the ditzy Lenny would
look like as a grown-up check her out
this design belongs to a deviantART user
nautical pudding and we love it her
dress is still the same color but got
fashionably upgraded and we love her
brown boots it's definitely the look she
could pull off and we can't wait for the
day the loud house has an episode where
they show official older versions of
their characters we have to say we do
miss seeing Lenny's white sunglasses on
this illustration they make her
character totally stand out wait until
you see how much our next character
stands out in her grown-up version
Laurie loud and last but not least let's
give a short tribute to the oldest in
the loud family perhaps Laurie and Lenny
should switch their ages because her
younger sister is definitely more
overprotective of other siblings instead
of leading by example the 17 year old
Laurie chooses to make everyone else
aware that she's the oldest and they
have to do as they're told
through out loud house blury is seen
constantly texting her boyfriend Bobby
she's also a huge muse for Lincoln's
best friend Clyde McBride who has a big
crush on her deviantART user nautical
pudding is really good at reimagining
the loud house characters all grown up
but their version of Laurie might shock
you she's the only character we've shown
you today with this upgrade in her adult
life check it out a 35 year old Laurie
is pregnant considering her family is
very large do you think she'd have more
than just one baby we wonder if it's a
boy or a girl
come on the loud house you have to give
us an official episode of all characters
in their grown-up version we
scene 11 siblings growing up in a
chaotic family in the loud house on
Nickelodeon it must be really hard for
the parents to deal with so many people
in the house but what will happen once
they have their own kids make sure you
watch this video until the end to know
what Laurie would look like as a mother
today we are showing you ten loud house
characters reimagined as parents Lisa
she might be the second youngest but she
is also the smartest girl of the family
it's incredible for someone to win a
Nobel Prize and she did it when she was
only a toddler and with so many
experiments equations and formulas that
she is working on all the time she can
only get better this is why Lisa will
probably be the best scientist in the
world she was in kindergarten when we
first met her but we bet that she
skipped a couple of grades and got her
doctorate degree at only 14 years old
that wouldn't be too surprising from her
now that she discovered a cure for
cancer and how to travel in time Lisa is
ready for a new challenge she wants to
become a mom but don't think that this
smart girl will ever have time to date
boys and complicated things like that we
think that her little son would probably
be another of her experiments as she
tries to clone herself and here she is
with her son as Cruella De Ville 84 and
Jay boy 32 acts reimagined her they look
so similar to each other that the crazy
experiment theory could totally make
sense no matter what Lisa will always be
here to answer his questions when he
asks why the sky is blue or how to
create a robot smarter than any human
but there is one thing that her son will
teach her the love of a mother is
something that you can't explain
Lola and here is our favorite little
princess of the loud family Lola loves
everything girly including pink dresses
and tiaras
she is really precious and the problem
is that she knows it this is why she
wouldn't mind seeing her 10 siblings
working as her servants princess should
have everything she ever asks for right
it would be hard to imagine her changing
diapers and cleaning the house but after
winning many beauty pageants as a kid as
a teenager and as a young adult it will
be time for her to meet her prince
charming and give birth to a new beauty
queen the loud family can't lose it
title after all and this new kid will
have to fight for it below low will be
surprised to find out that she isn't
expecting a girl but a young boy just
look at how Cruella De Vil 84 and J boy
32x reimagined them it seems like being
a boy doesn't stop this young man from
wearing a crown and loving the color
pink and with this cute little face we
think that he'll be ready to win any
beauty pageant his mother Lola will be
the best coat to teach him everything he
needs to know about walking posing and
smiling on a runway and with this
perfect look this young man will meet
his princess and see his fairy tale
story come true in no time Lana the twin
sisters don't have a lot of things in
common
unlike Lola this young girl loves
playing in the mud getting her hands
dirty and fixing things the more
disgusting it is the more interested she
is this is why this tomboy would
probably grow up to be a plumber and
she'll have fun doing it
and we think that this is how she will
meet the love of her life Lana is the
kind of girl who wouldn't mind kissing a
frog and finding out that he is a prince
charming that's because even though she
loves things that are ugly on the
outside this young girl is actually very
pretty on the inside and anyway boys
have been looking for a girl who is not
afraid to play outside for a long time
this is why it won't take too much time
for one of Lana's friends to become her
partner in life
the two will also have a beautiful
little baby together just look at how
Cruella Deville 84 and J boy 23x
reimagined them they look pretty clean
now but it won't take much time until
they both jump in the mud together and
get their hands dirty Lana will be happy
to have someone to play outside with and
her son will grow up knowing that some
things are more important than looks we
have never seen a prettier little family
Lucy with that dark look not a lot of
people would like to go near her but
once you get to know Lucy you know that
this young girl is actually really nice
she might be a little weird but that's
what makes people unique and we have to
admit that we all feel like her
sometimes Lucy doesn't seem to be really
into boys but don't forget that vampires
are actually really romantic this is why
she will probably meet a young man
we'll hate love just as much as she does
the two will be perfect together they
will even have a baby together just look
at how Jay boy 23x reimagined her Lucy
still looks like she doesn't care about
anything but she will probably never
admit that she cried a little bit when
her baby was born she took this
opportunity to dress him just like her
so she'll feel like she is not the only
one like that in the world anymore if
he's just like her we bet that this
little boy will be a very quiet baby the
game that they love the most is probably
peekaboo as Lizzy can surprise him every
time she appears out of nowhere if you
ever thought that Lucy's heart was cold
it will immediately be warmed up when
she holds her baby in her arms no one
can keep themselves from smiling when
they see this beautiful little face
Lincoln this young boy cares so much
about his sisters but it isn't hard to
imagine him growing up to be an awesome
father it is difficult for him to live
with ten other sisters when he is the
only boy but we know that his family is
what he loves the most in the world no
matter how much he tries to avoid them
we know that he will always be the hero
of these 10 young women we totally
understand why Ronnie and loves him or
we should say loves being his friend
because that's all they are we bet that
they will keep using this as an inside
joke saying that they are not dating
even when they'll be married their
daughter will even join them by saying
that she is not their daughter she is
just their friend just look at them as
sketch toons reimagine them Lincoln
looks really proud to be a father and
rowdy Ann is really happy to still be by
his side just look at her cooking
waffles for her kid as nelec reimagined
her being a mom totally suits her
growing up with ten sisters we bet that
Lincoln will love to have a big family
and this is why another artist
reimagined him with another baby however
he will realize that taking care of them
takes a lot of time and this is why he
will deserve a good night of sleep Lynne
here comes the best member of the loud
family at least that's what Lynn wants
us to think because she's the most
competitive this young girl loves to
play sport and always wants to prove
that she is better than her siblings
which can be a little annoying sometimes
but no matter what we love her like that
because we have to admit that she
actually is the best this is why it
would be hard for a guy to ever seduce a
girl like her Lin is so independent
strong and proud that many guys would
never dare to talk to her but no matter
what we think that she'll find someone
as good as her and they will be able to
compete against each other all the time
but the biggest challenge Lin will ever
have to face is probably being a mother
just look at how Cruella De Vil 84 and J
boy 23 eggs reimagine them her son seems
to have just as much energy as his
mother used to have but this time Lin
will have to learn that she can't always
be the best it's hard for her to keep up
as she is getting older and this is why
she now has a new mission she is now a
coach who will make sure that the sports
team of her son will be the best and
this is how she'll learn that being
better than others is not important as
long as you do your best
luan when this young lady is here we
know that we'll be hearing another joke
soon her siblings probably heard too
many of them and this is why they don't
laugh anymore but we think that luan is
always hilarious and we are lucky that
we don't live in the loud house because
we are not ready to be the victim of one
of her pranks having a sense of humor is
what most people are looking for when
dating so we bet that it won't take too
much time for this girl to get the
attention of a boy she likes but first
you'll have to impress her by showing
that he is the best audience and
laughing at all of her jokes but if he
really loves her
we know that he'll never stop laughing
Luann's kid will be really lucky to live
in this family just look at how Cruella
De Vil 84 and SP 99 stuff reimagined
them we think that this young boy will
never stop smiling with a mother like
that
and he'll probably make her laugh even
more with all the pranks that he will
pull on his family it's just going to be
crazy in this house and this is what
will make them the best family after all
those who laugh together stay together
and wouldn't it be great to see these
two stand-up comedians on stage we would
certainly love to be watching them
performing together one day Luna here
comes the loudest member of the family
no matter what time of day it is you can
always see Luna performing with all
these hours of practice it is not
surprising that she will one day be a
big star she already got the perfect
look and she is just getting better
every day when it comes to love we
already know who Luna has in mind it's
the beautiful Sam who is her love
interest they looked so cute together
that we hope they'll never leave each
other would it be great to see them get
married and start their own family they
would adopt a young baby and they'll be
happier than ever and together just look
at how sketch toons reimagine Luna and
her daughter whether it is during the
winter or the summer Luna wants to show
her daughter that she'll always have a
mother by her side however it means that
the artist would have to take a break
from a rockstars career to take care of
her daughter she doesn't want to be on
tour all around the world while her baby
is growing up and taking her first steps
but no matter what it will probably be
the best performance of her career this
little girl will have the chance to hear
the best lullabies when going to bed and
when she grows up she'll probably become
her mother's best inspiration Lennie
even if she is the second oldest member
of the loud family we have to admit that
Lennie is a little naive and ditzy but
we can easily forget about it because
she makes up for it by being kind and
beautiful Lennie is the kind of sister
that we would all like to have she is so
easygoing and happy-go-lucky that we
love having her around and this is why
we think that it won't take too much
time for her to find a boyfriend we
already saw that she had a crush on a
boy and we really hope that it works out
between the two falling in love will
probably make her even more naive we
won't mind as long as this is what makes
her happy
we hope that Lennie loved living with a
lot of siblings because she will have a
big family too
just look at how new Locke reimagined
her Lennie is more beautiful than ever
even if she has three kids to deal with
don't you think that those three kids
look like Lenny's younger sisters it
will be like the loud house once again
with all these characters having even
more kids it will be crazy to see them
together during Christmas time and no
matter what Lennie will be there to make
everyone smile Lauri and last but not
least is the oldest sister Lauri it's
hard growing up with many siblings and
having to take care of them because she
is the oldest she used to have all the
attention from her parents and then
ten more kids became part of her family
to steal the spotlight this is why Lorri
deserves the chance to be a little bossy
sometimes being the big sister comes
with a lot of responsibilities and we
understand why she would be taking
advantage of it sometimes but this is
also what taught her how to take care of
kids of every age and this is why she
will be a great mother and she will have
kids with her boyfriend Bobby just look
at how nautical Pudding reimagined her
surprisingly she is the last loud house
sibling to have a kid because she is
only pregnant now that's okay every
woman needs to wait the time it takes
for her to be ready to start a family it
might be your first child but we think
that Laurie would like to have a big
family it would be too quiet in the
house otherwise don't you think that it
would make a good sequel for the loud
house we would certainly be watching it
who is your favorite character on the
loud house don't be shy to tell us who
it is in the comment section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it for 10 loud house characters
reimagined as parents for more stories
like this make sure you watch 10 loud
house characters as body builders thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]